what happens to the stock market
depending on who ultimately takes
control of the House and Senate what
happens when it comes to GDP growth what
happens to unemployment and on and on
and on we actually have historical
answers you know every time there's an
election you see particularly the
American right-wing Republicans the Maga
people Etc fear-mongering and saying if
Democrats control this your 401k will be
worth nothing and if Democrats control
that then all of a sudden nobody's going
to have a job and GDP growth is going to
go negative and China will win and
Russia will win in all of these
different things and they say it with
such confidence but the great thing
about it is we have the data we know
historically what circumstances lead to
better economic outcomes and we don't
have to speculate and we don't have to
guess so let's talk about that right now
first a very quick word from our sponsor
policy genius we all hope never to need
life insurance but mortgage payments and
child care and other expenses don't go
away if something happens to us I now
have obtained life insurance in
particular because I now have a daughter
and it just feels good to be covered
policy genius was built to modernize
life insurance their Tech makes it easy
to compare quotes from top companies in
just a few clicks and find the lowest
price with policy genius you can find
life insurance policies starting at just
17 bucks a month for half a million
dollars of coverage policy genius has
licensed agents they'll help you find
options that offer coverage in as little
as a week no unnecessary medical exams
policy genius isn't even incentivized to
recommend one insurer over another no
added fees your personal info stays
private they have thousands of five star
reviews on Google and trustpilot you
deserve a financial safety net you
deserve a smarter way to buy it go to
policygenius.com
davidpackman show or use the the link in
the description get your free life
insurance quotes see what you can save
all right listen guys here's the bottom
line the economy does better under
democratic presidents
look it up all of the data is widely
available you look at Average stock
market return it's higher when a
Democrat is President than when a
republican is President you look at job
creation it's higher when a Democrat is
President than when a republican is
President you look at the unemployment
rate it's lower under democratic
presidents you look at GDP growth it's
higher under democratic presidents you
look at consumer confidence it's higher
you look at inflation it's lower under
Democrats this is not to say that
sometimes there are bad economic years
when a Democrat is president that can
happen but we never know ahead of time
what kind of a year any particular year
is going to be and what the data find
are that democratic presidents are
better stewards of the economy on
average as you know I don't recommend
timing the market I recommend broad
index funds low fee hold them for a
really long time set it and forget it
and in particular
that is a technique or a strategy that
just favors the averages and the
averages are stocks do better when
Democrats Are Presidents now there are
people who try to
fiddle with the numbers to achieve a
different result for example sometimes
Republicans will say you really need a
six-month transition pay phase and you
actually shouldn't start counting
performance until a president has been
in for six months you can do that right
it's a lag time it doesn't dramatically
change the numbers in favor of
Republicans try as they might to mess
with the numbers it really doesn't help
very much and so my view is don't take
my word for it fact check me unlike a
lot of these right Wingers I don't claim
to be the ultimate source of truth I
want you to verify the numbers I've
looked at the numbers myself and then
based on that actually make voting
decisions there's a lot of these right
Wingers where you give them the data and
they go yeah but Republicans are just
better for business well measured how
give me a metric give me a metric and
this happens often when you confront
people who believe in you know psychics
or Homeopathy or whatever and you say
show me the date
and then they go this is beyond the data
the data can't even capture this you're
no longer talking about reality when
people talk in that way fact check me
tell me where I'm wrong